PhD student in computational
Neuroscience um before I studied
Neuroscience I actually studied
theoretical physics so one of the people
I've always been fascinated by is
Einstein and the other week I read the
fascinating book by Walter isaacsons on
Einstein's life and I really enjoyed
reading it and learning about this super
particular character from his marital
struggles to his War activism but aside
from that something that I also realized
reading this book is that Einstein has
quite a particular way of approaching
science approaching physics that I think
would be really interesting to try for
myself for 24 hours and I hope by
sharing some of his routines some of his
habits and some of his learning
techniques with you that you could
perhaps implement it into your own life
so I will take you along to these 24
hours and let's get straight to day one
so the first thing I wanted to do when I
started reading about Einstein and
Einstein's routine is to really
highlight what made him so different
from other contemporaries at his time
and his age so the seven things that I
signed did is first he worked around 10
hours every day for around six days a
week the second is he used almost no
telephones no responsibilities and
acquired absolute Tranquility or he
turned off all unnecessary information
the third is that he always wanted to
prove things himself the fort is
teaching what you do now yet no the
fifth is playing music when stopped the
sixth is going on a long walk when
stumped and the seventh is pure focus
and concentration no matter the
circumstances so today I want to dive
together with you into these different
techniques and I'm a little bit worried
about some of them because I know some
of them will be a little bit hard but
let's get straight into it
so I just finished the three hours for
my morning coding session I have to do
some coding for University and I just
finished that and aside from Einstein
working 10 hours a day it was actually
also said that he tirelessly worked on
his problems and one can say that he
lives only for them and his wife also
says that I must confess with a bit of
shame that we are unimportant to him and
take second place so I do have to say
like although I do think Einstein is
quite an inspirational figure it is
quite well known that he gave up a lot
of things for his science and he was
really focused when he was working on
his science problems and I think this is
quite important because if we focus on
the aspect of him working 10 hours a day
it may seem that if you just work 10
hours a day you will magically produce a
lot of good work but actually something
that I've come to realize quite a lot is
it's actually way more important that
you put in some good hours with real
true Focus then that you put in some
random hours where you're just kind of
scatterbrained and not really focusing
on the problem at hand for example it he
also said that I am often so engrossed
in my work that I forget to eat lunch
and I think that really shows that
Einstein when he was working on problems
and when he was doing things he would
forget all about the world around him
and that's not to say that you should
forget to eat your lunch but it is to
say that try to instead of focus on the
amount of hours that you spent on the
amount of like deep work that you do or
the amount of focus that you have during
those hours that you spend and that kind
of brings me to the second point and
that was that Einstein was also well
known to turn off all notifications of
everything so he said no telephones no
responsibilities absolute Tranquility I
am lying on the shore like crocodile
allowing myself to be roasted by the Sun
never see a newspaper and do not give a
hoot about the so-called world and this
was from a letter he wrote to Max born
and I think this this really shows as
well how he lived in his daily life like
he was quite known to be quite
scatterbrained and sometimes not really
up to date with all the latest World
details or all the latest news and I
think especially in our age of
information overload we can learn quite
a lot about this so I think it's okay if
you have the ability to turn off your
cell phone for example or your email to
really allow yourself to be super
focused on your work because it's quite
well-known fact that as soon as you get
one email pop-up that that can kind of
disrupt the flow that you're in
foreign
for the last three hours on my paper and
a piece of code that I have to write but
I've been noticing that I'm getting
really really distracted and something
that Einstein has been known to do is
that he wanted to always prove things to
himself so he was set to tackle new
ideas by trying to prove them on his own
and this approach to learning physics
which came naturally to Einstein was
driven by a strong curiosity both to
know how things actually work and a
belief that nature could be understood
as a relatively simple mathematical
structure and another thing that he is
known to do is teaching what you do not
yet know and this is kind of similar to
the Feynman approach where you try to
teach your students certain Concepts or
certain things that you yourself are a
little bit stuck on and through the
process of teaching it to someone else
you actually come to understand it a
little bit better so I think this idea
is really interesting so if you're stuck
on a problem as well I would highly
recommend trying to use these two
techniques in your daily research
foreign
[Music]
all of the things in Einstein's routine
one of the things that I found really
interesting is actually the idea of what
he did when he got stuck because I think
a lot of us when we do research when we
go to university when we try to follow
our courses a lot of times we get stuck
in the problems we're trying to solve
and especially if you work in physics or
any type of mathematics related field
sometimes you notice that you just don't
know the solution and you just kind of
feel like the longer I work on this the
less I understand and Einstein kind of
did two things the first thing that he
did is that he played music when he was
stuck so music was no merit diversion on
the contrary it helped him think
whenever he felt that he had to come to
the end of a road or face a difficult
challenge in his work said his son Hans
Albert he would take refuge in music and
that would solve all his problems the
violin thus proves useful during the
years that he lived alone in Berlin
wrestling with general relativity and
the second thing that he did is that he
would go on these really long walks or
alone by himself or with friends so on
his walk back home at midday he would
often be joined by three or four
professors or students Einstein would
usually walk calmly and quite as if in a
referee while they prance around him
waved their arms and tried to make their
points when they got to the house the
others would peel off but Einstein
sometimes just stood there thinking and
I think by looking on this routine we
can actually get really inspired because
I personally really like these kind of
diversions that don't take our attention
away because actually diversions through
for example walking or music allow us to
have our mind occupied a little bit but
not so much that we cannot keep thinking
on the problems if you've ever studied
physics or mathematics you know that
sometimes you just need a day or two or
there just needs to be some time in
between until you get to the solution
but until you get that time it's
actually point of just waiting and
during this waiting instead of just
sitting in your room I personally really
like it to also play music so I play
guitar for example a little bit or to
not go on walks like Einstein did but I
personally do quite a lot of yoga also
because it's very rainy in the
Netherlands but I think it's a good idea
to just kind of go over your routine and
just really think about what kind of
diversions do you have that don't take
all your attention away but that can
help you in the moments that you're
really stuck and I would definitely
recommend something that's relatively
relaxing and something that's also not
inherently distracting like watching TV
for example
so I've tried to spend 24 hours going
over the routine of Einstein or the
Einstein method that he used and I want
to reflect on this routine with you a
little bit kind of the things that I
learned trying to implement his routine
trying to go over the different things
that he did and also how Einstein kind
of lived as a creative genius in that
sense and something that was actually
the most inspirational for me by reading
the book on Einstein by Isaacson Walter
is the realization that the one thing
that set him most apart is his
persistence and his utter Focus so he
also had these moments of pure
frustration or not understanding certain
Concepts but he works on them diligently
every day day in and day out and he also
never really lost his curiosity or his
focused mindset and I think that is just
the most important I don't think it's
these tiny details that he didn't wear
socks for example or that he sometimes
forgot to eat lunch I think it's just
the main theme for him that he was just
a really curious being and he found
almost any concept of physics inherently
interesting so training yourself for
Pure focus and concentration no matter
the circumstance is I think something
that we can learn from him so as a
review of Einstein's learning method I
would just say it's actually really
unpretentious in some way it's extremely
dedicated and also as Einstein himself
said he said I have no special talent I
am passionately curious and I think
that's something that we can all learn
just to be passionately curious about
the type of work that we do and
especially for me personally as a PhD
student in Neuroscience I definitely
have these moments that I'm really stuck
and I just think like what could set me
apart or what could help me in this
moment and I do really believe that it
is to just be passionately curious and
to just keep on trying to ask questions
and try to help people around you ask
those questions as well and then through
hard work you will find the solutions
yourself so I hope you enjoyed this
little glimpse into Einstein's routine I
would definitely recommend to read the
book by Isaacson Walter on his biography
as well as it was extremely interesting
and I hope to see you next week bye